welcome to zero playing whoo Baja wgm
boom bah yeah she's playing really well
I can't speak beating me once very very
clearly and then the other game I don't
even know did I witness at the end I
think I did but it was very lucky not
sure lucky is the right word but it
wasn't a clear we know anything okay she
plays the rear with Jeffrey and then
taking oh that's that's rare interesting
interesting way to play ok I'm going to
block this and go for a later f5 I
wonder if I should go for f5 with g6 or
not i guess i will do that there should
be seven castles and then neither way at
five was also kind of logical
not so sure what White's ideas okay so
show she shoosh shoosh so she wants to
go for F form let's prevent that with
nie Dage five
Jim it's not easy for y to play Herr
with the with the main porn break f for
being prevented yeah before that's
that's also something you can try and
let's do this try to make it a little
bit more difficult at least yeah I
wonder if I should if I can can first of
all player 5 hmm and also a 5 doesn't
move that I could consider playing you
even though Queen a four-episode t7
right will be a weakening in the long
run maybe our social do that make it a
bit more difficult with the be formal
Queen 84 Bishop g7 I can play Queen fi
brocade queen is trapped so Queen a4s
not a problem but why can go Bishop tutu
stuff like that maybe I should just you
cannot take yep so this means that I can
play a 5 now actually I with the Queen
being away from d1 after he takes fi can
take with the Jeep on so I'm happily
playing this yeah Queen 84 was really
not helping white and this is now
interesting do I go f4 or not f4 looks
dangerous in Kings Indian style yeah I
think I'm doing that
my bishop is silly on g7 but everything
else is very dangerous so Queen age
forearm I can also try to activate the
bishop over H for g 3 and so on it's an
interesting question 95 is of course
coming next i wonder if i should
actually just play c6 first and let's do
that plane c6 prevent any 95 not sure if
i needed to do that ok mmm nine to three
and push the pawns maybe yeah let's do
that come on it is pretty fastest this
kind of a check we watched positions not
exactly harmonious so forward
I have to be careful here with not
saying something that sounds entirely
wrong against a female opponent like
getting getting too wide with the pants
down or something anyway so Queen edge
for Queen a choice pretty dangerous I
really don't don't see how wide is going
to keep this this how i always go how
she's going to not lose here quite
quickly yeah so i can take age three now
but i can do so anyway so I'm going to
take it's probably better also opening
up that that diagonal it should be worth
something so checking here luck with the
king it was funny no this one so I hope
that's going to be the first first clear
win against her so now the rook is
unprotected so i can take on age three
she cannot take g3 as the rook is
completely hanging and now queen edge
for should be the end end of the game
you threatening to take on g2
white resign yeah yeah I'm satisfied I
think that was a was a very decent game
Queen Queen yeah I think the whole setup
here is kind of what has to be careful
not to drift into a somewhat passive
position here the center is entirely
frozen and the play is completely
reduced for me it's f5 and maybe c65 if
things are really going my way but
mostly f5 and white has possibilities of
f4 or be 41 of those two and yeah we saw
what happened to the f4 idea i just
stopped this with nida h5 how she tried
for b form and ya hear that was kind of
a five was a little bit of a beta move
to provoke Queen 84 which is really not
not helping and I think now it's
actually better to go back to the one it
looks awkward awkward but allowing me to
play a five cannot be right really I
couldn't play a 45 earlier because if we
check this let's say instead of a five I
go f5 um she takes I cannot recapture
because oops and this G 4 I mean
actually looked at this for a moment
because it is weakening here so it's not
like easily discarded something like
oops I'm sorry something like this might
be somewhat interesting but I already
couldn't believe it so now I can go
ahead five as after the capture I can
easily take with the pawn and the queen
is not looking at the night anymore and
this is a fantastic
I go bishops is six en g file great and
this and now okay I can take only form
not bad i have find it gets very
dangerous very quickly not sure about
this was just a precaution and now just
pushing things forward yeah I don't
think that why i can't get out this
engine is on minus 4 it's pretty pretty
rough j ok this is made in five okay
that was was quite okay i think thanks
for watching